[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for another session of st. Louis
chess club place that people today we
have Kayla of Gadsden who is actually
two points away from becoming a national
master so hopefully he'll become one
soon and see if you can actually take
your chances go to Lee chest challenge
us to a radio game place time control
only see if you can beat almost national
master Kayla all right so we have some
challenges already perfect make sure
it's a rated game because we don't do
casuals okay it's a play for keeps
around here alright okay so we have some
we have 25 people already watching nice
thank you very much joining us I know we
have a lot of people from the US and
from other countries internationally as
well so it's gonna be really fun alright
if you have any openings that you would
like us to play you can you can type
them on the chat and not 100% server we
can do it or not but if we if we if
Caleb decides to try it for you guys we
will do so okay I'll play any opening
okay perfect he will play any opening so
of course we're not gonna Mike comers
not here so we're not gonna play cc five
against everything when he's playing
black so just so you guys know alright
and of course a shout out to our men in
the back we have Issac Schwantz and also
Danny Machuca there is the link and the
chat to leech s our account so please
click it if you want to challenge us
okay
correct so our Isaac is typing out five
minutes or less as I deal that is
correct we don't want anything over five
minutes so if you do five minutes make
sure it's 5-0 no delay no increments or
anything because we want to get as many
people in as possible okay we have a
request can you play Edmonds gang gambit
when you get a chance yeah but they
would have to play a certain correct
correct so when you so we will try our
best so but if our opponents don't do
what don't do well we
them to do then we can't okay we'll try
our best what is your rating so like we
talked about in the show he has two
points away from becoming national
master so he is officially it's
efficient on us you have 92128
officially right okay 2190 officially so
he's two points away so we have here we
go we have blah blah perk defense please
London I played the piers and Carroll
Kong those are the requests okay so I
will write them down so we don't forget
about him okay and when I write them
down here we go first one was perk
second one was London
then it was Evans gambit then it was
caro-kann okay we will try our best to
do those okay obviously if our opponents
don't play the certain move we need them
to sway in order to do those openings we
can't do it we will try so somebody at
the beginning typed out five plus three
good control no 500 would be the longest
we will play all right please play a
Dutch okay I'll put that on a list as
well
okay so Caleb real quick when do you
expect to get that national master title
Oh tomorrow oh yeah okay speaking of
tomorrow well you know what that grace
of a good point let's talk about what's
going on tomorrow so tomorrow at the
singles chess club we have the
five-dollar Thanksgiving satellite which
is a g30 game time control and that is
dual rate is so it does count towards as
classical rating make sure if you're in
st. Louis make sure to stop by and play
you actually it's three rounds if you
win all three rounds and when I think
there's a Armageddon typed tiebreak if
you win all those you get free entry
into Thanksgiving open tournament which
starts on November 29th if you get free
entry that's great because even if you
pre-register tomorrow it's 80 bucks and
if you don't do it tomorrow I think it's
like 110 bucks so it's it's a good deal
it's a good deal make sure to come join
us if you can okay
all right perfect grant kramnik student
once it's challenged so that's been
interesting and we have a special
reception went away all right no special
visitors today
perfect all right okay we have more
requests but Nonie okay I'll put that on
the list but Nonie and then we also have
Dutch okay
I think it's that on list no it is
already on the list okay so we'll have
that Slav I'll put that on list as well
cramp so Kramnik student says if you
happen to play me my request is to play
me with full strength okay I think
that's so crap Tremec student I think
his rating is like 20 to something maybe
so is that correct
Christine I'm sorry if I underestimate I
don't remember quite but I do remember
when you played against GM Pepa Cuenca
and I think if I remember correctly you
were 22 something on Ches 24 maybe so
correct me if I'm wrong and I'm sorry if
I get it wrong okay
another request Danish gambit okay can
you play an opening that gambits your
team please
okay all right so we'll put that on
listen
greetings from Denmark thank thank hello
how's it going genic is a yacht Yannick
Yannick alright thank you for joining us
from Denmark played the Scandinavian
please okay we'll put that on a list as
well
Scandinavian okay well chromatic student
is an unrated player officially because
he only play plays online
what's your online rating twenty twenty
to fifty some James says cheers guys
how's it going James thank you for
joining us played the Halloween game but
you know I wouldn't usually accept
Halloween game except Halloween was
yesterday and that we are over that
already so we're maybe if we're bored
we'll try it but we're gonna not put on
a list for now Oh
somebody said caro-kann yeah so we have
perk London Evans game at caro-kann
Dutch but no knees sloth Danish
Scandinavian that's a whole this is I'm
gonna see if we get to get through all
that okay oh the core oak on okay but
then I transposed into something oh come
on you're supposed to play come on
alright I'm gonna go ahead and I
apologize for my my co-host here he's
supposed to play the Carol con but you
transpose that's our okay all right
Kramnik says crime next student says
check chess 2004 rating is 2400 oh okay
that'd be interesting interesting
[Music]
please place get in with - oh please
play the Scandinavian with two + f6 okay
we'll try that we'll see if we can get
to it okay I appreciate you taking time
to answer people's request Thank You al
say thank you very much we try our best
to fulfill our audiences requests okay
we will definitely keep on going with
that and thank you for joining us
appreciate it okay
Aska says when you know let's see when
you know what it is to play the boat has
gambit
I don't know what you're trying to say
there but I'll put the book that's game
it on the list okay
no problem Oh solitaire bad what's going
on my man no problem
I'll play that I'll probably play the
Carroll Khan okay perfect
all right ha ha James he's James says
you you're just scared of the Halloween
kamenashi yes we are not scared of
anything we we just said I begin a show
we will play any opening you guys
request however in the spirit of this
Halloween it's over already
alright you need to you knew that just
kind of go on with your life man go on
with your life
ha ha this is for Matt's good fun I'm
glad you guys gonna thank you very much
for the for the praise we try we try
kramnik student says I am capable of
playing like a noob though dropping a
piece within 10 moves dude that's
everybody you can't you can't just take
a key and just say that buddies that's
everybody so everybody drops pieces at
least sometimes you know Yannick Hanson
said love the same with Chess Club live
videos and online lessons I got got me
back from 15 years so out of chess oh
okay
congratulate them coming back
congratulations thank you for joining us
appreciate the compliments Ramiro from
Peru how's it going my man I actually
don't know any don't know any language
in South America so sorry about that mr.
Spock says hi Tony I was here yesterday
and I played the last game when she him
cry how's it going mr. Spock pretty sure
you joining us maybe go ahead and
challenge Caleb on a chest and see if
you can beat him alright the both his
game is when you belong or something ha
ha ha
awesome awesome oh so solitaire value on
the leech has your Bart X okay I got you
no problem alright perfect play the
Berlin alright I'll put that on lists
Berlin
James just kidding of course love it
funny dude okay what openings have you
played so far everyone's name pay
attention to your games I played the
modern and then I pull the coral Khan
and transposed into a modern okay so
we're gonna take care of Khan off the
list because we already tried to play
that even though his transpose we're
savanah count it right so next so here
it's Caleb here's your list so far perk
London Evans gambit Dutch Benoni Slav
Danish Scandinavian Berlin I have typed
up here so you know what I did the perk
is kind of basically a moderns right
take that over here all right we're
taking the perk off perk is I mean yeah
it's it was it was pretty we pretty much
got to have and you take that off okay
perfect okay so long London Evans game
at dodge but no nice lobbed a new
scanner name in Berlin okay we'll try it
no problem is that GM creative it is not
Anna in check what's up Oh what did
priyadarshan say oh really is you where
oh yeah play that word Berlin he would
say yes he is
okay ho was here hi Tony and Kayla
please teach me Thanksgiving opening the
defense of gambits what's the
Thanksgiving opening tell us well the
things see me opening yes and we'll try
to play it I don't actually know what
that is okay
ha yeah let us know what it is and we'll
try to play it thank you for joining us
so GM siding okay so we yep that it was
our man in the back saying that okay are
there two Caleb's at the same with
chesco there is there are two Caleb's
we have one right here Caleb Gosselin
who has two points away from peanin
national McMaster we have Caleb Denby
who is already in national master I
don't think he's here today but if he's
here he might come on the show and say
hi
the Kramnik student says I think Samuel
chess club is one of the best things
that has happened to the chess in the
recent years thank you very much for a
combo and crime in soon thank you very
much we appreciate it we try our best
and that is grandma that is a Grand
Master in the chat
maybe he will challenge us possibly
possibly possibly that that's actually
your your that's actually your your cue
Priya Priya - on to actually challenge
us oh that is so he is actually normally
a very very quiet calm guy but he's just
straight up making fun of you now we
beat you he beats you I did yeah all
right
Yannick says thanks I gained 250 Radian
points by watching your videos and I use
them when I teach chess oh okay awesome
I love it I love that you're getting
stronger because of us and I love that
you're actually using our maturity sure
I love it preciate your appreciate
everything that you do for us greetings
gentleman was also with you guys
yesterday with Qi and Jessie I'm not on
Lee chest I just enjoyed watching the
games tonight
okay perfect thank you very much for
joining us how did you get your fill of
entertainment watching our chat okay the
tax man if you could play one chess
player who ever lived who would it be
and why think about it right now you
have ten seconds go or fortunately
Korchnoi
you're he's your favorite chess player
of all time right okay why is that
just like his fighting spirit and how he
I don't know he had tantrums when he
lost which I thought it was funny
mm-hmm see that fighting spirit if if
you could if you could actually see like
hey loves spirit if when he said
fighting spirit it woman like fire hey
speaking of which I I said can you put
some kind of like energy around caleb is
that is that possible he's working on it
so maybe in next time when Caleb says
fighting Energy's gonna be like light
light up like a Dragon Ball Z alright
what is that time okay uh where's the
time control Bliss hunker in it so 500s
of longest we'll play okay any do you
want to play bully at all or just five
oh and three five one three okay so 500
and three two only please alright make
sure it's rated because we don't play
casuals all right play play for keeps
play for pink slips wait is that right
is that the right right turn for what is
it
okay pink slips boom as you you guys
probably don't know this but i but I
watch a lot of The Fast and Furious
movie franchise the other day so I'm
like a lot about cars now PD says ask
Caleb to play out the openings of Ron
Burnett I already do that Caleb just
wrote OGM yes you did yes you did that's
that's that's a challenge my man that's
a challenge I so GM says I am not having
very important I am now having very
important interconnection it would be if
not what I love the dual you know it is
2009 is this for us of 19 almost on 20
I'm sure you can get Wi-Fi any pretty
much anywhere so why don't you go go to
a coffee shop anywhere you know
challenges challenges if you can I mean
if you can't we understand we understand
are you scared oh that's true no still
alright shocked makan how's it going
how's it going challenged us to a game
please thank you for joining us thanks
for answering we we try our best thank
you for joining us taxman a scalable
your answer that all right no yawning
says who is the best chess player of all
time and why is he that so we actually
had that discussion two days ago so the
ones so our list of people did you win
or lose the first game everything I
played you whenever you alright we'll
give a hand to all the losers out there
all the losers out there there we go
nice try nice try
Priya dark night Ron is in u.s. not
India oh okay then you should definitely
get into connection a lot of places
cranek soon says that was nasty ex clam
yeah that was I don't notice how because
I was a pay attention but yet I was yeah
everything you play was nasty okay
that's what we're talking about there we
go have confidence right so Oh back to
the greatest of all time so we had a
discussion earlier this week with
actually GM Jesse and the considerations
we had to put the list together was you
have to be at least a one one time world
world champion that's that's like the
bottom line if you're not war champions
like what's the point of even
considering you right and the other was
how many years how many years that you
actually become a war champion defended
it and the third was what arrow chest
did you play obviously so Danny Machuca
actually had a good point
he his choice was Magnus Carlsen because
now you're able to use different
software's computer engines to actually
train yourself and with social media and
all that stuff nowadays GM's can
actually talk to each other at any time
actually train each other and help each
other out so his answer was Magnus
Carlsen all right let's see so
pre-adoption is it didn't work you yeah
we can show we can show this so junior
doctor said I am sitting in a random
city in Turkey right now in the USA
sub-junior team is only a few doors
below me right now oh okay
okay that's fun that's fun all right my
phone just rang I forgot to turn it off
my sorry about that so one of my
co-workers asks are you around today she
literally just saw saw me like five
minutes ago
[Music]
she said oh da you're on the air that's
sorry yeah yeah alright here we go
did the dumb that so he's asked the sub
tuna team how good their internet
connection is is it read that that bad
I'm sorry about that man
all right Avery said I am abject pong I
have challenged you to a 500 game yep
all right well we have a we actually
have a long list challenger so we'll try
to get to everybody okay so based on the
time frame we have we can probably fit
in about roughly around 10 to 11 maybe
12 games we definitely can't to get to
everybody but we will try our best to
okay if you challenge us to a casual
game we will decline it so make sure
it's rated and make sure it's 500 or 3/2
otherwise chalo probably decline
everything all right
alright Kramnik students Oh cake Kaden
motor for Kaden how's it going
thank you for joining us kramnik student
said I would I just finished seeing a
video of Kasparov where he was asked the
Q of who is the greatest and where he
rates Magnus it was with Lix Friedman
okay
how did he rape Magnus I mean he magnum
is drew Kasparov when he was like 13
years old right so he's got to be up up
on the list for everyone I mean okay
Yannick asked what's your favorite
opening and why is your why is oh gee
your favorite oh gee oh gee what kind of
what's what's oh what kind of gambit is
that do you play again beautifully give
it oh you are you sure those og right
there maybe he's calling Korchnoi you
know gee possibly oh that's that makes
sense that makes sense it's because he
is yeah yeah he is an OG that's why he's
his favorite well now he's a dead orgy
whoa whoa let's let's show show some
respect like that man all right let's
see kramnik students he said Magnus
so Kasparov said Magnus is a combination
of Titian and Karpov oh that's high high
praise even from like I know I know to
Kasparov a lot of even like the top GM's
today to Caspar all like everybody
thinks everyone's like that Oh
nobody's ready for him he's like one of
the greatest of all time and he has high
praise for Magnus so you know why
wouldn't he why wouldn't he who is your
favorite player so Cato favorite player
is course coach knowing my if you ask me
from my favorite player is I would have
to say
I'm just gonna go ahead and say Lasker
just because of like the number of years
he was war champion I have you know if
you talk about current players the
person the player I follow the most is
ding leader in from China I am of course
of Chinese descent and I follow the
Chinese team and he is number one from
China and he won the same field cup so I
root for him all the time I actually
even when he was here for the single cup
I was even a translator for him on air
and I was I'm minute in person a very
nice guy very quiet very shy but super
super nice super considerate so I'm a
big fan let's see to the who who do you
think is the best tactical player in
your view they're asking me yes well
they ask what I'm assuming it's you the
best tactical player ever yeah you're
mine yep Oh Ron Burnett Ron Burnett
that's why he plays a lot of opening
fire on Burnett there you go all right q
is it okay to make obscure references
concerning your opponents and mom and
where'd that get inside their heads let
me okay so the question is is is it okay
to make up seer obscure references
consider your opponent's mother in order
to get inside their heads so in response
from the st. Louis chess club we are
never we do not condone such my sports
might conduct okay dad that is our
official answer on the fifth
unofficially nobody can stop you I'm
sure somebody will be somebody will you
know get out of their zone if you try to
do that some people just offend pretty
easily so I'm sure it happens I'm sure
it works for some people but officially
we do not condone those things in my
experience the people who do such things
are just horrible at chess so they can't
help play their opponents on the board
so there you have it from Caleb now if
you are the one that's actually doing
that then he basically said you suck at
chess yeah you're but if you're not then
you're not then you're fine you know
all right duh a lot of comments here
okay Kasparov Anna says Kasparov also
said that at the rate at the rating he
retired he would have still been world
number two or number three for sure for
sure connect student said I still think
Magnus isn't right up there with Kat
really okay
okay I'm sure Danny are you are you back
there okay Kenny I'm sure if he was if
Danny would shoot I was here he would
have a lot to say about that but I mean
Kasparov is by some in some people's
minds group greatest of all time but
that is very arc I mean that dang I
don't know if you guys did hear this but
people are moving furniture upstairs and
it's kind of odd all right let's see my
favorite samhita to do Anna said you
feel that Casper I wanted to say I am
all-time best but was going around and
around and not gave me any names
yeah yeah he probably thinks he's the
best of all time Yannick says my
favorite player to watch is Luke McShane
love his style and there was a emoji
with a bulging bison good to know kram
extreme said I agree with Gary 28:51 in
1999 is way more than 2882 19 I agree
with that yeah I definitely agree with
that
dad-dad statement play in chess so we
played chess con for basically the last
two weeks because Jim Jessie cry likes
to play chess to come however usually I
would say like 90 percent in time we
play on lis chess okay they're just
easier for us to do it's actually we
actually like like playing on Wheatley
chess so that's why Caleb do you prefer
white or black pieces asked GM Priya
Priya
haha black I prefer to play black prefer
to play black yeah
because he's basically thinking like you
know what you can have the advantage of
playing white I'll still be you be right
yeah that is that is the
unconditional thought proper process of
a hey have you lost yet
no Bart x-bar Tex aka solid fat nice try
nice try you almost got it nice try okay
what okay what should your lob after
playing let's say two months if you were
going to become a GM just curious I
don't think those really correlate yeah
what do you what should Oh what should
be your yellow after playing for let's
say two months if you were going to
become GM I don't understand this thing
this are you talking about like if I
might goes to become a GM and then if I
start playing now like from from
starting now we're starting from zero
yeah I don't know that's that's that
can't be answer that's a I mean
different people have different can you
know climb at different rates if you're
saying like in general that's still hard
to answer if you were just playing from
if you're a new beginner player and
you're playing it for two to two months
like what at best
$1,000 your rating trajectory doesn't
really have to do with what you're gonna
become
correct correct even if your goal is to
become a GM that's still I mean you have
what's the percentage of people that
have a goal become a GM and actually not
do it a high percentage all right you
will say that most people aren't naive
enough to try to become grande a
grandmaster hmm
so there we go face I saw that on a show
today so I'm doing that is there any way
I can get more calls I'm sure we can
maybe we like to we like to give our
star star player any you know special
treatment date they request do you have
you lot lost yet no exactly a star
player star player I can't
how do you do a start with the star
there we go yeah there we go
so bark bark excess Thank You mr. Spock
says my name is whoa Logan hard as [ __ ]
okay I will try to get to you all right
I'll try to get to you
then magnus carlsen wind that random
fishers oh that's a good question I'm
not reassured I know last I know
yesterday uh so won the first two games
right let's check on that let's check on
that what is the Fisher random
championship
thank you I hope you don't like any
cream or sugar that is straight up okay
there you go all right let's see what
the results are for right now so today
today is final state number two because
they started finally yesterday and I
know that some people come into so in
their first two games so let's see what
it is
[Music]
okay so I'm reading here that what what
do I check out the oh there we go I see
it alright new schedule regular results
there we go results alright so as of
right now okay they actually didn't post
a five final results for you yesterday
okay we're gonna do something else see
we're gonna find anywhere else here
okay so right now so has the lead is the
so it wasn't so as a surprise leader
after they set exciting first day so so
is of course playing for playing he is a
u.s. player takes a he has a three point
lead so after the first day yesterday he
has a three point lead thanks to a win
in the game Game two of the rapid game
so so after first day so is the lead
alright then a duh okay so anis wait a
long chat here okay Anna says if you're
already an adult and start playing chess
no matter what you will never become a
GM is that true do you agree with that
John Shaw of Scotland became a
grandmaster and he was rated 1700 at the
age of 19 well so let's say less so
let's I know like the adult age is the
different for a lot of different
countries so in the u.s. if you're 18
you're a considered an adult so if you
started playing chess like new at 18
would you say you would never become a
GM probably not but but but the reason
is it doesn't have anything to do with
like talent or correct correct just have
to do with you have other things to do
correct now okay is there if you're
saying can you become a world champion
even that national champion when you
start playing that old probably
well if yeah that's not the gym you
can't become on that's true champion of
most country that's Carol all right
we're it's gonna we're gonna say most
likely not but they're as of course
anything there's always exceptions all
right all right Jacob Sanders ah it's a
Caleb guy bro aren't you in school
you're a junior aren't why are you
studying I mean I'm glad you're joining
us cuz I you know it we enjoy your
company well like dude you better have
straight A's so even when the third game
okay CEO says I am 19 and have been
playing since childhood but now study
chess for like six seven hours a day Wow
can I become a GM what do you say about
that so he started as a kid he's now 19
he studies six to seven hours a day can
you of course of course you can probably
not that you know what Sendhil sneha
want a challenge get him to a game maybe
if you okay give you some kind of some
kind of better diagnosis after you guys
play oh go for it
yeah I mean if you look I say if you
study six or seven hours a day that's
let's say you're off at above slightly
above average town level that's pretty
nemi that's don't believe in talent
don't believe in telling it what is the
word talent meet mean to you that's a
good question we're sort of natural
predisposition towards being good at
just for whatever reason maybe you have
but good spatial abilities I don't know
I just don't believe in it so to me if I
say talent for anything it's the its you
need let less time to Matt masters skill
than other person without talent so like
let's say talent for let's just say play
chess talent for playing chess if I have
talent and you you don't it so to me it
means you need more time to map master
ones aspect and I I do but what would
cause that
like in someone's brain would not like
nat natural born no pre that's what
you're right that's genetics yeah oh
yeah
you know don't believe it yeah it's but
like if if you were to live let's say
500 years you can master something that
I have a talent in as well you know
Jacob Santa says he he's still on he's
still going on about straight-a stuff he
expects too much of me of course if you
first of all if you're joining us in
while you're in school I definitely
expect a lot out of you okay you are you
are a member of the Chess Club and we we
love you take up that's why I'm worried
for you I I'm trying to push you into
you know push you into being being a
being a good student and being becoming
a great great adult I'm not there's
there's no there's it's only love
between us man alright Yannick says if I
ever going to visit USA I would love to
visit English trust me anyone come can
anyone just come visit the club follow a
lesson and is there free Yannick my man
when you're ever you're in st. st. Louis
please come to us first visit is always
free you can always get a lesson of
course so we have so we have classes by
GM's almost every single day a lot of
day so just come visit us we'll
definitely give you a tour or give you
some will give you you can join the
classes for free and check it out it'll
be fun I promise you you know not if
you're not from here you don't know but
we're in the neighborhood called Central
West End in st. Louis and it is really
fun we have a ton of restaurants kind of
things to do come come see us if you
can't all right please come see us Vince
oh nine is Miley chest count okay
challenges we'll try to get to you then
that done
hello again does they have to be rated
chest yes no casual games play play play
for keeps around here what's time
control two choices 500 or three - okay
Playboy bull Rex we'll try them our best
I did know we are did you win no I mean
that's going playing oh yes were you
playing oh man you better win cuz he's
in the trash I'll give you though
Jacob Sanders you get out 230 wow is
that true wait why is he gonna trash
told me I'm just guessing he's going to
miss guessing isn't likely usually like
anybody else okay all right Shane he's
got a 230 ok that's that's my bad maybe
school times a week so Jacob Lee
actually goes to the same high school
that I went went to way back in the day
so maybe thinking things change in the
last you know 10 12 years whatever it is
all right I think he has to do a
personality and personality at least a
little probably thanks shameless Chess
Club
hey yeah appreciate appreciate you
joining us man right this is my Jacob
Sanders as this my relaxed time where I
eat food and play chess okay okay
Touche Touche ana s is in Chicago if I
ever visit st. Louis I would definitely
be checking out the Chess Club you guys
are awesome and fine I appreciate your
comments and I appreciate it very much
and if you ever singles please stop by
we will love to give you a tour and show
you around
okay bar Searle says why why kids so
hung up on the GM title if you ever if
you learned and play you will develop if
you win tournament you will get titles
simple query chess bad choice probably
yeah I mean I'm assuming like people put
people play chess because they love it
but they go for the GM title because
they can make a career out of it you
know you can do look like people get
lesson from GM's charge like a hundred
and plus an hour if you ever want to do
just do chest for your entire life GM is
the way to go if you can get it see
Vince says how how to know about our cue
so we so when you challenge us our cue
populates and like and it goes by order
of who challenges first so we will we
will go will try to go by order as
it's rated 5 oh and 3 - those are the
three stipulations okay all right I
won't play a game now I'm not very good
though we don't care if you're very good
challenges challenges okay
hi guys love you mwah
Wow Stanley thank you for the thank you
for the air or the chat chat kiss
appreciate that appreciate for joining
20 are you joining us okay question in
your opinion should I focus on improving
my chess skill we're improving my kill
slash death rate ratio on Call of Duty
that's uh whichever one you in whichever
one ya whichever one you enjoy more man
if you're you know like eat like eSports
nowadays are huge if you can become a
call dude like professional Call of Duty
player I'm sure it's like the pay is
pretty much the same as GM and you know
that the age like you know how in in
chess you typically people say you're
your best years are like late 20s or
early 30s I'm sure you know if you video
games are kind of the same same thing so
you know this speaking of video games
like what what's the big big game down
every bleep place Isaac what's the gig
game that everybody plays nowadays four
nine yes thank you for tonight so I I
actually you used to run camps for kids
and believe it or not there's actually
summer camps that teach kids how to
become better a fortnight so that's a
whole other thing now so if you want to
play professional video games go go do
it go do it you can actually teach
people how to play all right how did the
Spice cup go I actually didn't keep
track of it but I know that I have read
that charissa yep because this spice cup
has become like her her story has become
pretty big like she's a youngest female
I am from in the US history she's broken
a lot of different records so great for
good for her that the Weslie wins again
against Magnus says Joe is that is that
today is that second day or is that from
yesterday this is ugly
Wow so so people will you see chat
written down from the st. Louis chess
club that's Isaac in the back so
obviously he's saying Call of Duty is
awful so he's saying pick chess he does
not speak for so he is a MMORPG player
he doesn't play first-person shooter if
he did he'll probably like Call of Duty
but you know we'll leave it at that and
getting wasted by who
so more xo4 x-man Yuri who's definitely
not using an engine you're a killing are
you is that sarcasm are you saying he is
alright here we go
mmm let's see here guys I like to have
an expert opinion my tactics rating is
quite high but I do quite well with
tactics but in real games my rating
seems to be have a downward trend do you
think I'm doing something wrong Caleb I
was too busy losing this game to hear
some tactics yeah so so so this guy says
his tactics were rating when he doesn't
is really high but when he plays in
there real real world over the board his
rating is going down well the wrong
means he has psychological issues
psychological issue so is it like a you
have like parent you know you you know
like mom issues dad issues no but just
facing another human being across the
board is a totally different thing than
just sitting there solving a puzzle I
actually kind of struggle with yeah how
do you get how do you get over this
we're gonna call it the call call this
you know in a sports world we'll call
this the yips so how do you get over
this oh I think you just have to play a
bunch and develop that fortunately
fighting spirit Korchnoi fighting spirit
there you have it that's what you need
okay okay I might have this one time is
he playing
unrated is he finding an Iron Mountain
Raider game no this is rated yeah
everything's ready we don't we don't
except on underrated games don't don't
play with us play with us because do you
actually I do remember you how's it
going
Jacob Sanders says Dan Caleb won't play
bullet with me so we are so here when he
plays Jacob sorry man he only plays
today he's only playing 503 too so if
you want to play him 503 - those are
your choices all right Caleb nice starts
- sarcasm uh-huh
wink wink like you said that NIS I felt
like I know that person she joins us all
the time okay Dani I saved this I played
a very nice tactic he'll see that
tactics time all right Stanley says I
play facebook Messenger chests okay
that's cool any any time you can play
chess as awesome barceló chess will be
forever fortnight is a fad and make your
choice of Korea yeah karai I told you
agree with you there I'm not yeah I
totally agree with you oh did you lose
oh I was on up day good good job old
rice if you can't hear well Rex Isaac in
the bag is laughing at Kayla because you
want a good job
nice nice guys swindle man nice game
nice swindle you you earned it Wow all
right
Klaus how how's it going
thank you for joining us do you accept
960 positions we do not we do not we
might do a show where we only play 960
or maybe some bughouse some other wins
but usually not not today okay and
here's a here's something if you want us
to do with some a show about something
else write us at info as st. Louis chess
club org okay I'm still waiting for
people to do that put in a good word for
me Tony Chen you know I'll try to make
it happen
Isaac is Walt walking out here for some
reason what's going on oh he's doing one
of these to me okay that's cool right
right back at you man hey I got you
okay what is Lee Chessmaster title with
st. Louis chess club oh we are LM which
means live lifetime master what is that
what it means this is Lee chess master
which is kind of like an honorary
meaningless title it's an honorary
meaningless so basically we are we of
course we're organizations so they will
give us that because we have GM's
playing so maybe that's why I have no
idea somebody says oh I see caution with
fighting spirit thanks perfect Yannick
says Knight nice to meet for the last
game yeah that was a yea vote bull Rex
good job 4x nice mate okay please look
out for my challenge by Snee he'll one
will try it I'll try it
just ass says Lee chess is lame bro what
are you talking about why don't we meet
chess lame you know I think lately chess
is about to take over chest con that's
like the most favorite chess chess site
I want to know the length of the queue
for the challenge what's the 11 we have
11 people we definitely can't get
through all the entire 11 because we are
already halfway through the show so we
probably get through another maybe like
depend on time control probably maybe
like six seven if some is if somebody
drops maybe eight I don't know all right
here we go
a non chess related question to Caleb
are you ready okay assuming he actually
know Monty Python but do you know you
don't all right he doesn't know my Monty
Python about that weird question okay
alright I am waiting from the start of
the stream what's your and Antonio
what's your what's your leeches name
Archie Connelly will try to get to you
not a problem okay
okay so Isaac wants me to tell you
please accept any rated games with 500
and 3 2004 from top to bottom gets the
people in the right order they don't
start from the top yeah okay as soon as
long as this rated in the time time
control you want that's cool okay right
sorry bro we're trying to turn a fixed
off man technical difficulties when it
comes to picking challengers sometimes
sometimes somebody has has a cool name
on lately Chaz knew not it was like you
know what we're gonna play that guy is
he a cool name and it happens from time
to time change to chest comm it's easier
to register there Lee chest takes a lot
a lot while possibly in the future we
might switch to chess calm or switch
between each other calm day from day to
day but right now it's Louie chess my
man mmm Lee chess offers free tactics
yes free lessons and facets a lot yes it
is that's why we actually a lot of
people that work at the single Chess
Club preferred leeches or chess calm so
a lot of times we play on me be chess
okay please accept my challenge
giant Google I me he so Gary who's name
is giant googa he is 11 years old from
New Jersey his rating is like 20 2015 is
that right Gary 2050 or is it 2250 ever
yet but yeah he's uh he's been on TV a
couple times
his is the real name is Gary his user
name is giant Guga he actually yesterday
he played a Jesse and he drew so I see
ving a beautiful we'll try to get to you
Gary we have a lock you in the queue so
we're not we're not sure if we can get
to you it doesn't matter to you love me
you're zoning you've been on TV we'll
try to get to you know no offense by
there but there could be a chance that
we won't get to you okay it should have
played see for God so I I think in the
chat says to him chess calm is more
about chess news and general chess in
Foley chess is a lot nicer to play on I
personally happen to agree with that
whenever I like to reach a chest news
like it goes to chess calm so
I agree with that Jacob Sanders says I'm
pretty sure they were doing chess comm
yesterday yes we were jesse was GM Jesse
I was here yesterday he prefers to play
chess at home that's all we did I
preferred the system where challenges
were prioritized if a person chata - ah
yes so we might do that we might do that
so it that so that system depends on who
is playing because that's what I like to
do but like some people when they're
playing they're like no I don't like to
do that I was like okay that's fine we
might try to do that in the future some
some GM's don't like it so I don't but
we'll try it next time okay so this time
it's basically who challenges first okay
I okay so Isaac said old man likes old
sites that's what yes that's actually
what Jessie cry exactly what Jessie
Christ said he said I'm an old man I
like she has that calm I don't change
things Tony don't forget about my
nickname John here I got you I got you
who so Matt Sullivan asked which which
site has bigger user base between Lee
chess and chess calm I think as of right
now chess calm does just because it's
been around forever but leach as I think
it's growing and I think one day will
take to take over in my opinion all
right what do you what are your thoughts
on that
stop Patriot Johnny I need peace on you
Timmy Caleb what do you mean who do you
what do you think about who has the
bigger you userbase HSHS calm surely
chess calm oh really yeah okay cool I
mean probably chess there's more common
among very serious number serious
players serious players but just calm is
like the default thing that people drag
Leon when right just want to play catch
now if you win against Caleb you're
welcome because it's my job to distract
oh that's alright
Oh
well I don't know actually oh it's gotta
be bad
let's see that uh what's up with Caleb
struggling against these 1400 players
who are definitely not using an
engineering wink is Anna you are
speaking to Caleb's heart because he's
just saying he's thinking all the
sarcasm of all engines hilarious alright
okay you win or lose
I've got this one in the bag yeah end up
back so you better resign whoever there
you go yes listen oh good job
9s game I give you a hand for that one
what's your record today gotta go
oh yeah colleague Sean Collier on you
rock my oh I don't know I lost won one
game with that in game swindle yeah
swindle see he used the worst window
because he was definitely planning on
winning but then there was this to be
right I swindled somebody and when does
a win in my book doesn't matter how you
get it so it's cool all right Yanik
asked what's your favorite gambit to
play and why oh I don't play game that's
really well-known oh I played the
Queen's Gambit make sure make sure you
play our opening it's London London
Evans game at Dutch but no nice lob
Danish Scandinavian for Berlin okay
right so right now he is playing the
Queen's Gambit yes yeah so there they go
that's his favorite game but he's
playing right now watch it
alright Jacob Sanders comments exactly
an engines are you that's why bullet is
the best way to play chess and off okay
you and your bullet oh my god and dang
dang okay get Gary are you living over
from New Jersey ask what's your favorite
chess opening for white and black and
why for white I don't know I like
playing against the King's Indian
for black the month look probably the
French actually hmm there you go
keys Indian and French all right is
there a reason why we're just like this
just cause they're just closed positions
that I think I understand better than I
understand the other ones but not
necessarily well gotcha gotcha so so
Gary are you loving her was saying play
me I can be beat him well so we're going
to order Gary as long as we get to you
we will definitely play you we're not
trying to not scared we are just trying
to beat up on Caleb we're not oh yeah
that's true that's true
yeah so just that commented Lee Chester
for grandmasters chess calms for
everybody I kind of I kind of somewhat
agree with that statement so okay John
Google I'm will try bro we'll try
alright
what does LM mean so LM when you're
looking at our screen means leach has
mastered that's just the honorary title
that we that our account gets because we
are organizations that has many like
grandmasters play as well right
what is Gary wants to know what your
USCF so he is two points away from
becoming a national master he is 2198
that is officially as US you have a
rating okay so you can check it out
Kaleb Gaston what is what is his u.s.
just curious Gary
he said earlier 2020 15 20 50 okay he
probably couldn't beat me oh oh we're
moving my night beautiful get to him
alright
like he actually did did draw cry it
yesterday now that that's that's
something
okay in my own mind I am a chess master
SS family congratulations bro that is
the right steps right first step you
always think you're a grandmaster
Siraj thanks guys thank you very much
for joining us bro what warder says Gary
it's the order you challenge us so when
we when we see our challenge queue the
challenges go from top to bottom in the
water they've challenged us in so that's
why we're trying to go in that order
okay
Jacob Sanders wants to know if you are
playing or TV in the satellite tomorrow
he's playing he's playing cuz he's
trying to get that last two points
become an international master Jacob
stands Center says I think I'm gonna
play in the you 1800 okay okay if you're
if you want to if you you know maybe you
should play in the open and just play me
yeah just play in they no open have some
cojones as they eyes heard on to TV the
other day I'd like to use our words
pretty cool Gary says I have QC rating
points okay alright calm yourself man
calm yourself mr. Spock says not only
for and want to play Caleb okay I don't
know if I believe that but alright Gary
says impressive brah I'm 1 years old
guys guys let's stop with the
exaggeration okay
chess is about truthfulness alright my
rating on lis chess is twenty to fifty
says Gary okay all right all right cool
Touche Touche kudos how are you doing
Gary from the new jersey how are you
doing on your on your patents have you
invented anything new yet I'm curious so
as so you guys don't know look up Gary
lijinsky he actually invented some
device I forgot what it was to sort to
to help kids and it's pretty awesome
so if he anything new
let us know oh I think I can play Queen
takes e6 here sixty-six Queen takes you
to reach a king h1 and I don't see any
more checks mmm
should probably be meeting or something
there you go she's definitely meeting
all right I got a question for you
Yannick has a question for what's the
what's your in your view what's the best
way to improve your game in my
experience just do a bunch of tactics
just do a bunch of tagging and play a
lot of serious games and don't think
about openings at all so if you see so a
common theme when we get asked that
question everybody says different a
couple of different things but the
common theme is you should always play
more like more experience gets you more
bit better I always play play more games
mmm eight so Gary's pattern is a a watch
have you done anything new since then
alright garius the local genius here he
is man gary is he's got like you know
high chess trading been on TV has a
patent that's probably making him you
know millions of bucks when he's 11
years old probably honest second patent
for something kudos to him kudos to him
somebody said the Benoni but no only
correct okay so on on our list I won't
mean what have you played have you
played the London yet no Evans gambit no
Dutch no but no one you yes okay
take it but no knee off the list how
about Slav no Danish no Scandinavian no
Berlin no bro you are falling behind
what's wrong with you you can't get just
get whatever opening I understand that
but like people are gonna blame you
that's okay yeah alright Gary says yes
he is working on a second matter but
it's a secret
oh okay okay all right cool can't we
will Gary I know you're only 11 are you
are you on social media oh I would like
to follow you go make sure I I get the
next patent when I see the next patent
when it comes out I'll be pretty cool
Kayla
Jacob Sanders says Kayla please play the
Dutch for me so Dutch is on our list for
him to play we will try our best to get
it okay
Yannick says thanks for the answer nice
mate Caleb oh yeah I thought it was nice
too I wasn't paying attention the game
but if I did I probably see that's a
nice problem
I for something for some reason we have
like people chatting a lot which is the
free is awesome which is awesome how far
am I in the queue I have to go to work
early if it's too far back I will cancel
and play some other time couldn't
Kramnik student oh he's an ex your your
next crime next student say on the last
a stay on it and play us all right work
we needs to work on sick or at least say
your car broke down so you can be okay
being late that that's what I Isaac does
all the time so it's cool burn no no
come back
Isaac all right are you asleep back
there
and then here all right so curious Oh so
Gary's on Instagram Gary to cheer you
alright I got you man I got you thanks
bro so I eyes like type Z pull up the
queue again we see you real quick
where's giant words giant Google I see
alright your giant Google you are way
down man your your we so we have half an
hour left we probably won't get get to
you I'm sorry about that but if you
actually join and joint like on our next
stream join in like exactly a3 or
wherever we start we probably get to you
all right I mean you you have patents
I'm sure you're making a lot of money
you can buy like five or you know a
bunch of different alarm clocks you know
just set set the time and challenges bar
sorrow says Caleb can you get a good
game if you totally neglect learning
openings I mean learning or not cramming
up on long lines yeah of course off
course I don't know I mean I think I've
had some good positions and I don't know
any openings dude you literally like 10
minutes ago you just said my favorite
openings are the friends I play like
obscure sidelines okay
okay and there you go I Isaac was saying
he's beaten some seventeen hundred's and
had some good games against 1900s never
once studied open opening good yeah so
do tactics and as Jesse Christ said go
over your game so you can learn from
your mistakes and play a lot because the
experience is key for that's the common
theme from everybody play get experience
play a lot Jacob Sanders says just play
the London if you don't want to learn
all openings okay that's what's pretty
good Gary asked when is the next dream
so the next dream is since cities rise
next dream is Tuesday 12 p.m.
time okay so if you're in New Jersey
what is that e 11:11 a.m. so right now
Tuesdays we it's 12:00 p.m. local time
Wednesday Thursday Friday is it's 3:00
p.m. local time
okay and I think we might be adding a
show or two maybe on Saturday not sure
as of yet but when we do we will make
sure to post it on our social media so
you can check it out all right what's up
what's dream for with who me by yourself
what what time okay so I so Isaac is
telling us he's gonna have a stream
going out tomorrow play against him he
doesn't know what what time so we can't
tell you what it is come come tell us
come tell us about this all right here
we go
here's Isaac so my work schedule just
changed and now I work on Saturdays so I
could do a stream on Saturday so we
could have one more stream and I'm not
amazing at regular chess and we do lots
of regular chess throughout the week so
I thought I would do variance what okay
we I mean we have set we have sabina
Flusser here can she be on the show
tomorrow if she's the one wants to yeah
absolutely
what time do I did what you don't know
what time yet right I was thinking
either either noon or three I was
thinking because those are our two
streams starting times maybe because
it's the weekend we should do a little
earlier because people actually be
around to watch you know there they
won't be at school and such or work
let's do noon
let's do noon tomorrow noon tomorrow
noon tomorrow there will be uh hey let
me let me check what time Sabinas
actually supposed to be here tomorrow so
we can actually so tomorrow Sabina who
is Sabina Foster for former US Women's
Champion he is our resident Grandmaster
starting today but she's actually not
here
she says you go 12:00 to 6:00 tomorrow
okay perfect
and I'm sure to stream until I get bored
of it so it might be kind of long I
don't know yeah perfect perfect join us
join us see you tomorrow guys all right
here we go
all right let's continue on
[Music]
oh wow okay okay here here see you here
see you okay Jacob since Anna says I'm
calling it right now Caleb's gonna lose
to a two thousand tomorrow
dang dang Wow we have to say about that
I can try it I I can trash talk for you
okay Jacob what are you like a 1500
runner right now are you kidding me you
shouldn't be in the conversation this is
me talking for him not not me all right
just so you know really like Feingold oh
I'm waiting guys giant Google I got you
my name is my name send me a challenge
I'm not gonna Gary we're not gonna so
you're talking with somebody else like
an Airlines all right okay the Vicky
0.95 username well we're so we're going
by the order of the time you challenges
in so if we get to you in the next 25
minutes you'll play if not you have to
do it tomorrow all right
can you play vole Rex again
unfortunately today we can not because
we only play one person one time in a
day so we're still we can get as many
people in as possible all right so he is
done for the day he won so
congratulations and let's just let you
should end it on a high note all right
what is LM LM is Lea Chessmaster that's
an honorary title given to our
organization by me Ches Jacob Sanders I
like he says
Isaac should play tomorrow he can't play
tomorrow because he's actually streaming
the show so he will be able to play are
you saying he should play on the show
tomorrow he might we're gonna try to get
our GM and residents to play but if she
can then he'll probably play
and when is the next stream when you
live in Denmark ah don't know the time
difference but it'll be noon tomorrow
local time so do some math figure it out
man
okay give Caleb a cup of coffee
he's very sleepy is that true you don't
how do you feel normal
so he's fine calm down danger just lose
to him what is what's the job of a
resident GM so we always have a Grand
Master in residence here at all times
every single day
their job is basically teach our classes
that we have here teach private lessons
that people when they request it and do
stream for us alright those are
basically the three main things they
have odd jobs here and there like we we
like to visit some do some community
events they might go with us so that's
basically what they do I eat chess for
breakfast Wow alright congratulations I
guess
are you a grandmaster yet if not then I
guess you're eating just for nothing
what's the salary for GM in st. Louis
chess club oh gee are they are they
there and teach for free I actually
don't know what the what the going rate
for GM when when we have them here for a
couple weeks I don't know the rate is do
they teach for free they teach our
classes if you're a member of the Chess
Club you can attend any classes for free
but you have to be a member and there's
a membership fee of course it's pretty
cheap where our nonprofit but so classes
that you can join for free if you
remember however private lessons there
is an extra charge I think it's like 75
dollars an hour as opposed to normally
it's like $100 for GM's
so slightly cheaper here but that's
basically the rate that's a lot of money
Stanley that's not true I if that was
true I think more people will try to
become GM's
and now Jacob Sanders has not come from
Tony he's barely I thought I told you it
wasn't coming from me it's coming from
him I don't think you guys go by to
order challenges very well when I
challenged you guys the stream you guys
said almost immediately all right we'll
try our best I don't know how to solve
that problem all right
caleb has some of the most intense
thinking postures I've ever seen on
chess players whoa okay you mean like
this did this thing that he does yeah
that's pretty intense
none when and where the next grand chest
tour when okay so the next so there are
two more Grantchester events left in in
the year 2019 one is one is super bet
rapid and blitz and that is Romania and
that's let me see when the actual data
is what November's it's happening pretty
soon just make sure I don't give you
guys the wrong wrong date here so yeah
November 6 so that would be next
Wednesday I want to say that starts
super bad and that's Romania and then
after oh sorry there's three events left
Tata Steel November 22nd that's the
second one and then the last one is
London that's GT finals December 2nd you
can all look at the dates in play places
and the players the player field go to
grand chests org okay
is Eric Rosen still there he is in st.
Louis however he is not that he is not
in residence here he comes here a lot
but not here as a right now is it true I
am grandis of masters and is really rich
I own many Honda Civics do you okay all
right ah is it sure you're sure you're
the grandness of all masters I guess if
you own a lot of Honda Civics yeah
I think I have a nice position as long
as I'm not blundering any tactics a very
nice position there you have it a crap
climbing student we have a oral Caleb
has a very nice position against you
yeah I'm actually meeting Kramnik
student in the style of cram
ding-ding-ding burn burn burn are how
much better yeah but I think I would
prefer black you're not I mean you can
say if you're telling the truth II not
better we're gonna say yes we are much
better maybe he should switch his name -
Caleb student Oh
oh wow I have never heard this much
trash on Ricky oh this is awesome
hey let's go cranny student please
please if you lose please switch your
name - okay let's see oh my god is
little arias oh that's good I love it
all right now I'm gonna lose after
saying oh our friend Mohammed said ooh
you are magnus carlsen
because it was that are you talking
about the Honda Civic thing that's cool
all right duh why you can't find a move
move when you can't find a move move
upon this is this is witchcraft if
something's going on here this can't
work all right yeah I'm just winning
okay all right crime soon I'm gonna do
your favorite and this in try to
distract hail the kid have a card for
you do you ever lose loose faith in your
chests how do you overcome such pairs or
chest dumps oh one second I really want
to win this game well I got two minutes
no I've recently I haven't lost faith in
my chest because I've been studying a
lot and I think that's probably the
solution is just to study a lot I think
I think if you do study consistently and
well you're it's very unlikely that
you'll have a streak of bad news and
there you have it there you have it
Yonex ass is Jonathan going to do more
chess openings explain it's some of the
best chess online I actually agree with
that it's actually he is very the
information you get out of Jonathan
stream it says top notch Isaac what are
your what's the answer to that is
Jonathan Lee gonna do any more of those
chess opening explain okay so we're so
we're gonna say probably not just
because so if you guys don't know this
Jonathan became the manager of the Chess
Club to wait three months ago and
because of that his time to do streams
has gone down he usually does streams on
Tuesdays for us however like it's hit
and miss cuz he has a lot of
responsibilities so for for chess
openings explain we're gonna say no all
right Isaac how do I like block some of
these messages read the mess guys this
is a kid-friendly show stop stop saying
stuff that's not kid-friendly like where
like you start starting from from here
it's like like stop it love it I'm gonna
flood
you better not youuuu you're trying to
change his name tonight
halo student you better not lose this I
have a good position but I'm gonna flag
that happens to me a lot
crime next student I can't wait for your
treasure shock if you win this game I
want to see what it'll see you're
shocked mean Jacob Sanders it isn't your
Chet isn't your chest and eat snack time
over yet shouldn't you be studying
force Jonathan to do them
Denmark nee needs it ah I don't think
there's anybody that can actually force
him to do it we can always ask unless
like the very top management says go
Dewey he will but that probably won't
happen but he actually does like to do
streams as if he has too many too much
things to worry about
and I have Gary key asking you have one
game just Bey based on how much time is
left and are a list of people we're
gonna say I'm gonna say probably very
likely not didn't hot cranek see when
you are putting Caleb through the rings
here
dang shoot Jesus s shoot beside my
second Oh criminy I'm just gonna go
ahead and say crominus games going why
not know dang well after all you oh my
god losing after always he has to win on
time you can't win on the board
oh is that you Wow okay I mean this is
still pearly a drawl when is it Wayne
man when's a win I'm just gonna keep
moving back and forth
oh no it's exciting still a draw you can
even take the night and it's a draw but
he's gonna flag me he's gonna flag me oh
wait yes yeah oh but no it's just a draw
oh he's gonna yeah he's a scoundrel
let's not let's stop with then let's not
start with the name crawling here all
right
just cuz he's I did it all you did is a
draw yo
uh-oh crime is student you were like
this close I drew him with the black so
he still has to change it tonight good
still have to change give me a for that
one good job good job
okay alright it's this guy's next
let's see here Jacob Sanders says man I
have to do a lot I have to do a whole
bunch of government work from when I had
the flu
I got to do like four things where
procrastination is key said like a true
teenager I'll give me a hand for that
one that's that's all Canadians are like
that you know you know program nation I
actually my my little sister is now a
senior in high school and she
procrastinates like nothing else like
she's crazy crazy
let's see Klaus says it seems that
Magnus will not be a super bet he's not
on the list of players on Grantchester
comm did he withdraw I don't think so no
I I'm not sure how to answer that
question 100 I will check on the check
on it and let you know I'm not sure what
the but like it's he's it's Magnus I
figured he'd be invited to like every
one of them right actually say so Isaac
has informed me that the not all 12
players can go to every every event
because you gain too many points so you
can only go through a certain amount
that's why okay all right nice game I
guess you're only 11 you're so good at
Chester can you make an exception Gary
no exceptions man sorry bro no
exceptions
alright it least not today
nobody's not today because we have we
made the point of saying we're gonna go
from top to bottom when it comes to the
queue I think we're gonna have to play
the next game Tony why I gotta use the
bathroom no ho hold it you have 10
minutes left holding I've been holding
it forever
hold it this is another form of
distraction oh yeah well it's just
compounding the other distraction it's
that's yes that's the point it's the
point
this is a challenge kramnik student says
thanks for the thanks for playing him
uh-huh
alright procrastination is the sister of
perfectionism so there's a good in that
bar sir oh I'm not sure if I agree with
that but all right
I'm not sure if I could do that one all
right yeah no feed a tournament Vince
all nine okay who do you think will win
the candidate and why what do you think
will win so Kenneth there's still four
spots that right there so four spots
left in the candidates right now there's
only four that's guaranteed so if you're
just asking who among the four that are
qualified right now who's getting in my
I told you my pick is ding leader in
because he's my food he's when I follow
all the time what do you think so ding
waha Caruana and who's the last one for
is this so could be so what do you who
do you thinks gonna win candidates oh I
don't really keep up with the top
players but okay wait doesn't didn't
read job over and earn a spot to the
candy oh yeah he did yeah Dorian because
I think he's old school
hmm I always root for the old geezer
so Vikash asked be 45 or e4 c5 what's
your favorite I don't like either of
them don't like either of them there you
have it there you have it
make sure I play see far more than e5 so
I prefer c5 to e5 but I still don't like
either Oh
the ultimate distraction he is Jacob
Santa says why do you think Tony was
forcing you to doing so so much of otter
Kayla sees a big for you the ultimate
distraction it's coffee but so savory a
little liquid there's a hilarious
hilarious hilarious all right no man
sorry hang on guys I'm trying to do some
stuff on Twitter here all right
aye I think so Muhammad says I think
Carolina has a really good chance yes I
think we actually as so as a club as a
whole we kind of root for all the bait
basically all the American players and
kuranes is up on the list top of the
list so we do as a as a club we we do
cheer him on okay Sani says my elo is
now 9002 Wow
all right Wow so I have to say about
that all right I have to say about that
when is the candidate I'm not sure when
the exact date is I'll look it up for
your hands again
da-da-dah
[Music]
there we go sorry my computer is
freezing a little bit okay
[Music]
all right so it looks like that both
call canisters all chuckling I'm trying
to read this dang it all right it's some
it's some time net next year let's just
say so say that for right now before I
find it
chess tournaments calendar World
Championships 2020 2020 all right so you
are looking at
[Music]
all right I can't look at my my computer
is dying I can't look it up it's um
sometime in 2020 all right here we go
Caleb can you checkmate with nine moves
depends on the position Abbas says take
his place honey no no we want to we want
him to play on even though he is wanting
to go to the bathroom
I think he's gonna search it he might
hear fight that's actually pretty
hilarious if he does he says he had to
go to bat so I think he's gonna start
I'm gonna drink some coffee right right
right by is really the business that's
pretty hilarious okay uh Roger buff did
really well yes you did goodbye Yana can
see thanks for coming Yannick thanks for
joining us man thanks for very much hope
to see you soon
[Music]
okay
l40 and stock fish sarcastic clap haha
okay all right I mean I'm sure Caleb can
check me somebody in three moves
depending on how the opponent moves you
know sometimes I can even check in one
move one move how do you do that well
just take take your one is king in this
slap in the face with it yeah okay there
you go that's how you win one will take
his king and then go Shh
it's how you doing I can't believe it
okay we don't have time for another game
after this because it's 4:30 right
correct so whose is it
shock shock makan this strike makan
right now it's a lot last game Gary you
are not you're not even close on this
man and he this is the last game because
we are out of time we have to we have to
stop stop the show at 4:30 so this is
the last game are you losing on time
right now you have 18 seconds are you
kidding me dude I took like a minute for
that last move but man you better like
pre pre pre move about is winning like
you can just move the bishop with well I
don't well yeah like Bishop c4 choke 9
if to chick takes Queen takes Rick
everyone
Jacob Sarah says I mean if caleb has to
go he has a desk to cover the dance he's
gonna ever after show NZ it's gonna
start out of here and go to the bathroom
that's hilarious if you guys can't hear
that squeaky sound its Jake this uh it's
Caleb's chair he's like he's like he
hasn't gonna happen he's a scary guy
right I resent him alright take your mic
off and then go he has to go to the
bathroom oh sorry guys okay we go it is
he resigned he has to go you all right
go just go run run my man okay we are
out of time thank you very much for
joining us this is a really great show
hope you join us tomorrow at noon see
you guys later
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club